also ich habe gerade eben Sahra
Wagenknecht ja eine der hauptrednerinnen
heute gesehen und ist zusammen mit Oskar
Lafontaine ihrem Mann hier angekommen
gerade vor ganz ein zwei Minuten wird
das gewesen sein er ist schwarze habe
ich auch meine ich schon gesehen also so
wie es aussieht kann es wahrscheinlich
hier pünktlich losgehen man hört es
jetzt hier im Hintergrund hier wird auch
noch mal verschiedene Parolen skandiert
ähm vielleicht ganz interessant wäre
überhaupt auf dieser Veranstaltung ist
wir haben hier mal ein paar
Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmer gefragt
das hören wir uns vielleicht einmal an
deswegen hier und der dümmste Regierung
Europas und dem Herrn Max zu sagen das
ist doch nicht weitergehen kann ich
befürchte den Dritten Weltkrieg dafür
habe ich Angst
haben sie auch ein bisschen Angst bei
dieser Veranstaltung das wird ja Vorfeld
viel diskutiert auch von rechts das so
ein bisschen unterwandert wird z.B Tino
Propeller ist ja einer der Unterzeichner
des Manifestes das hoffe ich nicht also
die steht hinter dem steh ich auf gar
keinen Fall wenn wir in Deutschland
keine rechten und linken haben Geld
Deutschland Bach runter Punkt Ende
sei froh dass es noch Querdenker gibt
die haben nicht ein bisschen was im Kopf
die querden häufig es gibt ja der Plan
aber es gibt auch
Rechtsextreme das ist ein ganz anderes
Thema jeder Mensch der hier mitläuft und
aufrichtigungen für den Frieden ist kann
konservativ liberal oder
linksradikal sein das ist mir recht aber
was halt überhaupt nicht akzeptieren
wäre wenn es hier rassistische oder so
nationalistische Gruppen gäbe das wäre
nicht akzeptabel und ich denke da hat
sich die Veranstalter auch davon
abgegrenzt wenn sie es in Ordnung wenn
auf dieser Veranstaltung rechts und
links gemeinsam also extrem rechts und
links gemeinsam demonstrieren würden
wir diese Eingruppierung verstehen
sowieso nicht letztendlich ist hier
jeder rechts der für Frieden ist ob er
links rechts in der Mitte oder sonst wie
jetzt hauptsächlich für Frieden und er
ist so so anständ IG dass ich wirklich
für den Frieden einsetzt und nicht nur
heuchelt
ich verlasse ja das waren mal ein paar
Stimmen von Teilnehmerinnen und
Teilnehmern also diejenigen mit denen
ich gesprochen habe das waren vor allen
Dingen die Teilnehmer in der an den
ersten Reihen die haben alle noch mal
über viele von denen haben noch mal
betont dass sie eben nicht links oder
rechts steht sondern dass sie
Friedens bewegt sind und das auch ganz
interessant das sieht man glaube ich auf
den Fahnen auch hier hinter mir es sind
erstaunlich viele friedensverfahren
friedensflaggen zu sehen eigentlich
Flanken die man so aus den 80er 90er
Jahren des letzten Jahrhunderts noch
kennt also ein bisschen Revival das
haben auch einige Teilnehmerinnen und
Teilnehmer gesagt bei mir ist jetzt
Rainer braun
internationales Büro für Frieden
sie sind einer der ersten Unterzeichner
wir warten ja jetzt gleich auf die Rede
von Sahra Wagenknecht und alles
schwarzer macht ihn so ein bisschen
Angst dass zum Beispiel auch ein Tino
krupala die gleiche Erklärung
unterzeichnet hat wie sie als erstes
haben 620.000 Menschen die Erklärung
unterschrieben ich kann nicht jeden
kontrollieren
Angst macht dass wir nicht mich freut
dass so vieles unterschrieben haben und
mich freuen die Bilder die ich jetzt
hier sehe das sind friedensbilder und
jetzt der friedenswelle unübersehbar und
Nazis habe ich noch nicht gesehen die
hätten wir ja rausgeschmissen von daher
ist eine wahnsinnig eindrucksvolle
Friedensdemonstration und das freut mich
und wir zeigt einfach dass wir mehr
werden in diesem Lande die ich für
Frieden auch wieder auf den Straßen
engagieren und das wird hoffentlich
herausfinden auf die Politik in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten haben aber
Frieden heißt ja für Sie auch das ist
keine Waffenlieferungen mehr an die
Ukraine geben soll das Ergebnis ist doch
klar das wird doch ein sofortigen
Zusammenbruch der gesamten Ukraine
bedeuten der Armee dort Frieden heißt
das allererstes Waffen das Töten muss
aufhören das gegenseitige tägliche
morgen dann als Frieden Verhandlungen
Verhandlungen aller Zeiten unter
internationaler Mediation und
Beobachtung und wir brauchen dazu keine
weiteren Waffen wenn die Waffen
schweigen aber Waffenstillstand heißt
das müsste eine Abkommen geben und das
heißt ja auch man müsste dann
beispielsweise ein Wladimir Putin
Vertrauen würden sie ihm dann Vertrauen
überhaupt noch ich will erst das
verhandelt wird dass man zusammensetzt
und aushandelt was wir überhaupt haben
will das heißt also kein waffenstopp
sofort sondern erst Verhandlungen erst
waffenstopp sofort und dann
Verhandlungen die Waffen müssen
schweigen dann Verhandlungen
Verhandlungen führen zu einer Ergebnis
dieses Ergebnis Bedarf internationaler
Kontrolle Überwachungen möglicherweise
UNO Blauhelme braucht
sicherheitspartnerschaften braucht auch
Länder die es kontrollieren das alles
ist ein großes Paket das ausgehandelt
werden aber dazu müssen das allererste
die Waffen schweigen aber das wird auch
gleichzeitig bedeuten dass sie
Freundinnen Ukraine sofort
zusammenbrecht und Russland hat ja
deutlich angekündigt was ist dann macht
wir hatten ja mit werdet das ist ja der
stellvertretende Vorsitzende des
Sicherheitsrates der hat ja vor zwei
Tagen noch gesagt wir würden dann die
ukra mir sofort einnehmen und dann auch
noch mal die nato-grenze Polen in Frage
stellen es geht doch dann auch weiter
noch einmal
waffenschildern heißt dass die Waffen
auf beiden Seiten Schweigen nach
waffenschüchern beginnen Verhandlungen
über eine Lösung eines ganz
komplizierten Problems zu dieser Lösung
gehören keine weiteren Waffen zu dieser
Lösung gehören Rückzug der russischen
Truppen zu dieser Lösung gehört eine
Lösung für Donbass und nur ganz und für
die Krim und den Beginn einer
neuorientierenden europäischen
Friedensordnung aber dafür muss
ausgehandelt werden muss überprüft
werden das Wort Sicherheitsgarantien von
Ländern und ich will noch mal sagen die
letzten Sicherheitsgarantie für Münster
2 hat jemand anders zerbrochen
zerschlagen nicht die Russen von daher
ist die Schuld können wir jetzt
gegenseitig immer wieder zuschieben wir
müssen aber wieder verhandeln verhandeln
müssen alle die jetzt auch Krieg führen
und viele dazu damit ich sie jetzt noch
mal fragen aber ihre Forderung ist auch
ganz klar und da sind sie mit der
UN-Resolution der Generalversammlung
kommen sie damit überein Rückzug der
russischen Truppen
Frieden Friedensvertrag in der Ukraine
bedeutet auch Abzug der russischen
Truppen bedeutet Frieden für ganz
Ukraine bedeutet eine friedenslöse für
uganz das beinhaltet auch ein Abzug der
russischen Truppen im Rahmen einer
gesamtfriedenslösung erste Schritt dazu
es Waffenstillstand und Verhandlungen
dankeschön erstmal Herr Braun und wir
warten jetzt ja hier noch gleich und das
wird denke ich mal so in ein zwei
Minuten losgehen auf die Rede von Alice
Schwarzer und Sarah Wagenknecht aber
vielleicht gebe ich jetzt erstmal noch
mal kurz zurück ins Studio dann darf ich
eine Frage noch stellen können Sie denn
inzwischen überblicken wie viel
Teilnehmer zu dieser Veranstaltung
gekommen sind man hat ja im Vorfeld von
ca 10.000 gesprochen haben sie da schon
irgendwas erfahren können
leider gibt es noch keine offiziellen
Zahlen also ich habe auch mal versucht
ein bisschen jetzt zu schätzen die
Polizei hat ja vorhin gesagt na ja wegen
der schlechten Wetters könnten es
vielleicht nicht so viele werden wie mit
wie viel man gerechnet hat aber einige
tausend sind es auf jeden Fall und ich
denke mal dass ich mehr im Laufe der
Veranstaltung dann auch die aktuellen
Zahlen von der Polizei geben lassen
werde
vielen Dank Bernd und wir schalten
natürlich sofort wieder live zu Ihnen
wenn Wagenknecht und schwarzer auf die
Bühne treten nach wie vor bei uns im
Studio dr Frank Umbach ich würde gerne
dieses Argument dass diese Veranstaltung
dass das Manifest sich und zu reichen
abgrenzt gegen die AFD aufgreifen
zunächst mal es war ja nun seit Monaten
schon so dass die AFD für
Friedensverhandlungen und
Waffenstillstand eingetreten ist also
kann das hier eigentlich jemand der
einen Manifest für den Frieden macht
nicht überraschen wenn es denn ich höre
gerade dass es in Berlin losgeht und das
Schalten wir natürlich sofort live hin
[Musik]
zur Weltwirtschaft schon seit vielen
Jahren Berater für verschiedene
internationale Organisationen wie die
Vereinten Nationen die Weltbank der
Internationale Währungsfonds und die
welthandelsorganisationen er hat in der
Vergangenheit sowohl den
UN-Generalsekretär als auch die
russische und die ukrainische Regierung
beraten und heute ist der Direktor des
Zentrums für nachhaltige Entwicklung der
Columbia in der Universität in New York
und Präsident des un-netzwerks Lösungen
für eine nachhaltige Entwicklung ich
finde das großartig dass Jeffrey Sex für
uns für unsere Kundgebung extra ein
Grußwort aufgenommen hat er hört es
gleich und seht es gleich auf dieser
woldertrüben mit Untertiteln auf Deutsch
ich hoffe es ist gut hörbar und gut
lesbar vielen Dank ja ihr Lieben
wir sind gleich wieder live bei der
Veranstaltung wenn dann die Live reden
auf der Bühne beginnen als Wein können
wir noch mal dieses Argument aufgreifen
haben sich schwarzer und Wagenknecht
ausreichend distanziert von
Unterstützung aus der rechte extremen
Szene aus meiner Sicht überhaupt nicht
also es musste erwartet werden gerade
weil die Positionieren der AFD ja zuvor
bekannt war wobei das auch innerhalb der
AFD ja nicht unumstritten ist weil die
AFD kennt sich ja nicht so einer
grundsätzlichen pazifistischen Haltung
Sie Beate die Bundeswehr sie bejaht hat
auch sehr stark dafür plädiert dass die
Bundeswehr auch mit militärisch wieder
stärker werden muss und aufgerüstet
werden muss und dementsprechend hat die
AFD diesbezüglich natürlich auch einen
Glaubwürdigkeitsproblem und deswegen gab
es auch innerhalb der AFD ja eine
Debatte ob man tatsächlich sich
offiziell mit diesen Gruppen mit einem
sehr stark fundamental pazifistischen
Haltung sozusagen Alliierten alliieren
sollte aber auch warenknecht und Co
müssen sich das fragen denn es kam
natürlich letztendlich nicht
überraschend und auch gerade in der
Sendung von Frau wagen sich bei Herrn
Lanz und auch in den Äußerungen von
Herrn Lafontaine wurde ja deutlich dass
sie eigentlich um diese Frage eigentlich
sozusagen herumgehen ja also man will
sich einerseits natürlich nicht
vereinnahmen lassen aber andererseits
begrüßt man es nach wie vor dass die AFD
sozusagen gemeinsam diese Positionen
vertritt und auch bei der Kundgebung
dabei sein ich würde an der Stelle gerne
mal Sarah Wagen nicht wirklich zitieren
sie sagt jetzt wörtlich jeder der
ehrlichen Herzens mit uns für Frieden
demonstrieren möchte ist willkommen
genau und das ist genau das wo andere
dann sozusagen natürlich auch ihre
Probleme haben auf Seiten dieser
Kundgebung auch wenn sie eben nicht wie
Herr farbig ihre Unterschrift da
zurückgezogen haben aber Bauchschmerzen
bereitet das natürlich schon und
nochmals niemand konnte da entsprechend
überrascht sein und die Positionierung
von Wagenknecht macht ja deutlich dass
man sich eben genauso wie ihr Mann
überhaupt nicht hier von der AFD
abgrenzt und die sie sagen wieder ist
denn eine Sache schon allein deswegen
falsch nur weil die AFD sie auch fordert
nein natürlich nicht sondern man muss
sich inhaltlich mit den Positionen ja
auseinandersetzen ja und da ist mir
zunächst mal es auch egal ob das jetzt
die AFD ist oder
Frau Käßmann ich glaube wenn frau
Käßmann
Opfer und Täter hier gleich setzt wenn
sie davon spricht äh von den Lehrern der
Geschichte da muss man einfach noch mal
vielleicht auch daran erinnern dass wir
eine seltsame Lehre der Geschichte hier
in Deutschland haben ja die im Rest
Europas ganz anders wahrgenommen wird
der zweite Weltkrieg ist eben nicht
durch eine pazifistische Haltung leider
auch nicht durch die Widerstands kennen
Kämpfer sondern tatsächlich durch die
Alliierten und durch Russland durch
massive militärische Gewalt beendet
worden ansonsten gab es keinen Frieden
im Zweiten Weltkrieg am Ende gegeben man
musste Hitler und das Hitler regime
beseitigen und das ging eben nur durch
Gewalt und insoweit haben wir deutschen
verständlicherweise natürlich die Lehre
gezogen nie wieder Krieg wir wollen nie
wieder solche Eroberungskriege führen
aber der Rest Europas hat natürlich eine
völlig andere Lehre gezogen nämlich dass
man auf der Hut sein muss das
Beschwichtigungspolitik easement-politik
wie im Vorfeld genau das was wir im
Vorfeld auch von 2014 mit der Krim
erlebt haben wie auch danach ja genau
diese Politik hat
letztendlich zu dieser Eskalation
entsprechend geführt und das lässt sich
in dem Reden von Putin auch nachweisen
jetzt haben sie ja gerade in ihrer
Argumentation die Parallele zum Ende des
Zweiten Weltkrieges gezogen letztendlich
hat militärische Gewalt den Diktator
Hitler besiegt wenn ich das jetzt
übersetze heißt das dann wirklich das
ist gar keine andere Lösung gibt als mit
militärischer Gewalt denn Diktator Putin
zu besiegen und von der Macht zu
entfernen nein dies wesentlich
begrenzter die Zielsetzung ist ja
ausgegeben und die die Ukraine muss
befähigt werden ihre verlorenen Gebiete
sozusagen wieder zurückzugewinnen und
Russland sozusagen an den
Verhandlungstisch zu ziehen ja niemand
erwartet im übrigen ist die NATO auch
militärisch gar nicht in der Lage auch
die Ukraine ist nicht in der Lage selbst
wenn sie russisches Territorium
sozusagen beschießt ja dann ist sie aber
nicht in der Lage was weiß ich bis nach
Moskau oder so zu marschieren und Putin
da aus den Sesseln zu heben also das ist
weder die politische Zielsetzung noch
könnten wir das mit dem militärischen
Mitteln sozusagen bekommen in Zeiten des
Kalten Krieges haben wir immer
unterschieden zwischen einer
strukturellen offensivfähigkeit und
einer Niederwerfung Strategie wie sie
der Warschauer packt hatte die eben
vorsah die sowjetischen Truppen in einem
Ernstfall auf Deutsch ist alliiertes
Gebiet sozusagen
marschieren zu lassen und dort die
alliierten Streitkräfte niederzubringen
wir haben aber umgekehrt wäre die NATO
auch damals nicht in Zeiten des Kalten
Krieges in der Lage gewesen das was wir
als invasionsfähigkeit bezeichnet haben
aller wie Napoleon oder Hitler aller
Moskau zu marschieren ja auch damals war
die Zielsetzung politisch wie
militärisch sehr viel begrenzter und das
ist in dem Fall sozusagen auch der Fall
es geht darum dass die Ukraine sich
selbst und ihr Territorium
völkerrechtlich legitimiert entsprechend
verteidigen kann man muss sich
vorstellen nur an absurden Vergleich
aber diese historischen Parallelen sind
nur da so wie Putin sie ebenfalls
aufmacht wir würden eine Lepore
Regierung in Frankreich bekommen mit
einer extrem nationalistischen Richtung
aller Russland und eine solche
französische Regierung würde das
Saarland Baden-Württemberg oder andere
Gebiete Deutschlands wie sie Vorfahren
und Jahren mal auch zu einem
französischen Königreich gehört haben
wieder sozusagen zurückerobern wollen
das ist völlig absurd und wenn das
Schule nur macht dieses Beispiel und das
haben wir mit der Grimm
Produktion 2014 gelernt dann öffnen wir
die pandora-boxe hier in Europa weil
dann sind gar keine Grenzen mehr sicher
ein kleiner Blick auf den Monitor da
sehen wir live Bilder aus Berlin also
nach wie vor noch keine Redner live in
Berlin wir unterhalten uns nur so lange
bis es dort losgeht wenn wir das richtig
gesehen haben dann ist auch Oskar
Lafontaine da kurz auf der
Tribüne gewesen ich bisher ist er nicht
als Redner angekündigt sondern nur
Wagenknecht und schwarzer viele Menschen
machen sie sich sorgen auch die
Unterzeichner dieses Manifest dass da so
mit diesen Waffenlieferungen eine eine
Rüstungsspirale in Gang geht am Anfang
haben wir nur defensive Waffen geliefert
wir erinnern uns noch wie lächerlich das
inzwischen vorkommt dass die
Verteidigungsministerin da 5000 Helme
geliefert hat dann waren es Luftabwehr
Waffen und jetzt sehe ich gerade das
alles schwarz und Sarah Wagen echt die
Bühne wieder betreten und da wollen wir
natürlich nichts versäumen
ja also wir fünf werden jetzt in der
kommenden Stunde reden ich äh für alle
kurz ein
wer Sarah Wagenknecht ist muss ich euch
ja nicht sagen
[Applaus]
aber vielleicht sagen wir beide euch ein
paar Worte darum warum wir ihr Schulter
an Schulter stehen das ist ja ganz neu
und für die meisten sehr überraschend
und wir haben uns tatsächlich erst ein
Tag vor Veröffentlichung des Mannes
manifestes zum ersten Mal persönlich
getroffen ja also es ist tatsächlich so
die Vorgeschichte dieser großen
Kundgebung die ist gar nicht so lang
sondern es war im Januar als die ganze
Debatte über die Panzer hochkochte
erinnert euch damals haben wir noch
gedacht vielleicht kommt es gar nicht
dazu aber alles diskutierte darüber dass
Deutschland jetzt endlich Kampfpanzer
liefern muss und da hat Alice mir
geschrieben eine Mail geschickt und hat
gesagt so jetzt reicht's jetzt müssen
wir was machen und da muss ich sagen
weil ich begeistert
und
ich habe ihr dann sofort
zurückgeschrieben ja natürlich wir
machen jetzt was und so kamen die Idee
einen Manifest für Frieden zu schreiben
was wir dann auch zusammen getan haben
und dann haben wir ganz viel Leute
gefragt dass sie das Unterschreiben ja
das Ergebnis kennt ihr alle aber wir
wollten eben auch nicht nur ein Manifest
schreiben sondern wir haben gesagt das
muss auch auf die Straße die
Friedensbewegung muss wieder auf die
Straße und so kam die Idee zu dieser
Kundgebung und wir sind total glücklich
dass das heute stattfindet und dass ihr
alle da seid
ja genau nicht nur heute das ist doch
ganz klar der Anfang einer
Bürgerbewegung und da kann man nur
hoffen da da kann man nur hoffen dass
die Medien und die Politiker da und die
Politikerin auch bitte ja das Begreifen
also da hat gerade gesagt das ist meine
Fest haben wir ja zusammen verbrochen
und Corinna Kirchhoff die viele von euch
kennen Schauspielerin wird das Lesen
aber sie ist nicht verantwortlich dafür
sie ist nur mit Unterzeichnerin nicht
das nicht dass ihre Gegner gleich morgen
im Theater faule Äpfel werfen
heute ist der
352 es geht nicht an hier
heute ist der 352 Kriegstag in der
Ukraine
und mittlerweile ist es schon der 366
über 200.000 Soldaten und 50.000
Zivilisten wurden bisher getötet
Frauen wurden vergewaltigt Kinder
verängstigt ein ganzes Volk
traumatisiert
wenn die Kämpfe so weitergehen ist die
Ukraine bald ein entvölkertes zerstörtes
Land
und auch viele Menschen in ganz Europa
haben Angst vor einer Ausweitung des
Krieges sie fürchten um ihre um die
Zukunft ihrer Kinder
die von Russland
brutal Überfallene ukrainische
Bevölkerung braucht unsere Solidarität
aber was wäre jetzt solidarisch
wie lange noch soll auf dem Schlachtfeld
Ukraine gekämpft und gestorben werden
und was ist jetzt ein Jahr danach
eigentlich das Ziel dieses Krieges
die deutsche Außenministerin sprach
jüngster von dass wir einen Krieg gegen
Russland führen
im ernst
Präsident selenski macht aus seinem Ziel
kein Geheimnis
nach den zugesagten Panzern
bitte Ruhe damit ihr Corinna hören könnt
die kleinen Residenz gemacht aus seinem
Ziel kein Geheimnis nach den zugesagten
Panzern fordert er jetzt auch Kampfjets
Langstreckenraketen und Kriegsschiffe um
Russland auf ganzer Linie zu besiegen
noch versichert der deutsche Kanzler er
wolle weder Kampfjets noch Bodentruppen
senden doch wie viele rote Linien wurden
in den letzten Monaten schon
überschritten
es ist zu befürchten dass Putin
spätestens bei einem Angriff auf die
Krim zu einem maximalen Gegenschlag
ausholt
geraten wir dann unaufhaltsam auf eine
Rutschbahn Richtung Weltkrieg und
Atomkrieg
es wäre nicht der erste große Krieg der
so begonnen hat aber es wäre vielleicht
der letzte
die Ukraine kann zwar unterstützt durch
den Westen einzelne Schlachten gewinnen
aber sie kann gegen die größte Atom
Macht der Welt keinen Krieg gewinnen
das sagt auch der höchste Militär der
USA generell Miley er spricht von einer
patzsituation in der keine Seite
militärisch Siegen und der Krieg nur am
Verhandlungstisch beendet werden kann
[Applaus]
warum dann nicht jetzt sofort
verhandeln heißt nicht kapitulieren
verhandeln heißt
Kompromisse machen auf beiden Seiten
mit dem Ziel weitere hunderttausende
Tote und Schlimmeres zu verhindern
das meinen auch wir
meint auch die Hälfte der deutschen
Bevölkerung es ist Zeit uns zuzuhören
[Applaus]
wir Bürgerinnen und Bürger Deutschlands
können nicht direkt auf Amerika und
Russland oder auf unserer europäischen
Nachbarn einwirken doch wir können und
müssen unsere Regierung und den Kanzler
in die Pflicht nehmen und ihnen an
seinen Schwur erinnern Schaden vom
deutschen Volk wenden
[Applaus]
wir fordern den Bundeskanzler auf die
Eskalation der Waffenlieferungen zu
stoppen jetzt
er sollte sich auf deutscher wie
europäischer Ebene an die Spitze einer
starken Allianz für einen
Waffenstillstand und für
Friedensverhandlungen setzen jetzt
[Applaus]
wenn jeder verlorene Tag kostet bis zu
1.000 weitere Menschen leben und bringt
uns einem Dritten Weltkrieg näher
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so ich möchte euch eben noch
[Applaus]
hallo hallo
wenn wir hier fertig sind dann geht ihr
bitte in die Nacht ganz Berlin und in
die ganze Welt und redet und diskutiert
weiter aber jetzt machen wir mal eben
hier neben mir steht Hans-peter Waldrich
und er weiß Bescheid er war schon sehr
aktiv in der Friedensbewegung der 80er
Jahre
da waren da glaube ich noch die Grünen
dabei ja das ist sehr lange her
und Hans-Peter Waldrich Hans-peter
Waldrich ist vom Beruf Politologe ich
glaube nicht nur das also da kommt
einiges an Kompetenz zusammen und an
Lebenserfahrung
daneben steht Erich Fahrt
general ade
[Applaus]
und viele Jahre viele Jahre der
militärische Beraterin von Kanzlerin
Merkel also da kann man ja nur
nostalgisch werden nicht also das dann
würde jetzt vielleicht jung aber weiß
ich wir wollen nicht spekulieren auf
jeden Fall Erich hat gehört
sehr schnell gehörte er zum enkern mit
Sarah und mir und als wir drei gesagt
haben das machen wir da wussten wir das
wird was so jetzt bitte Hans Peter
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde des
Friedens
der letzte Staatspräsident der
Sowjetunion Michael Gorbatschow hatte
eine großartige Vision
er nannte sie das gemeinsame Haus Europa
das gemeinsame Haus Europa
in dieses Haus ist eingebrochen worden
an den Fronten
massakriert sich die ukrainische und die
russische Jugend
im Hinterland wird zerstört getötet und
vergewaltigt
das muss beendet werden
[Applaus]
jeder Tag den der Krieg noch länger
dauert
produziert Leichenberge
aber
es gibt ein sehr ernstes Problem
das Haus in dem nun die Einbrecher wüten
ist voll gestopft mit Atomwaffen
vom Keller bis zum Dachgeschoss Lagern
hochmoderne heidekwaffen
die spielen den Planungen der Militär
ist eine wichtige Rolle
was würden Sie tun wenn Sie an einem
Haus wenn Sie in einem Haus wie Europa
das eher eine Pulverfass gleicht einem
überfallenen Land helfen wollen
sicher würden sie vorsichtig sein
sie würden kein offenes Feuer anzünden
und auf einen unkontrollierten
Schusswechsel verzichten
sie wollen ja helfen und keine atomare
Katastrophe anrichten
aber wir haben doch die Abschreckung
höre ich rufen
wegen der atomaren Abschreckung sind wir
doch sicher
und Putin so sagen viele der Tod doch
nur mit Atomwaffen um uns zu erpressen
welcher Angsthase wird er noch einen
solchen blöd hereinfallen
wissen Sie was
die Story von der atomaren Abschreckung
ist ein Ammenmärchen
damit beruhigen sich Leute die wenig von
der Sache verstehen
kein wirklicher Experte der
atomarenabschreckung hat jemals
behauptet dass diese Abschreckung sicher
und für alle Zeit funktionieren wird er
im Gegenteil
lassen Sie mich etwas Persönliches sagen
schon vor 40 Jahren
war ich sehr aktiv in der damaligen
Friedensbewegung engagiert
die weltweite Friedensbewegung war
damals mit die Ursache dafür dass der
Kalte Krieg zu Ende ging
wir alten friedensbewegten sind immer
noch stolz darauf dass wir daran
mitgearbeitet haben
demonstrierten weltweit Millionen
Menschen
und vielleicht haben sie von der
Menschenkette gehört die 1983 zwischen
Stuttgart Neu-Ulm stattfand
bei einer Neu-Ulm befand sich damals
einer atomwaffenstützpunkt
stellen Sie sich vor eine
ununterbrochene Kette von Menschen die
sich alle an den Händen Fasten über fast
110 km
teilweise stand die Kette zwei Reich so
viele Menschen machten mit alle wollten
nur eines
die Gefahr der atomaren Bedrohung bannen
endlich Schluss mit einem Leben am Rand
des atomaren Todes
das war damals
damals wussten die Menschen noch wie
gefährlich Atombomben sind und dass sie
jederzeit losgehen können
heute
heute wissen sie das nicht mehr
wir kommen Politikerinnen und die
Politiker wie raumtänzer vor mit
verbundenen Augen tanzen sie auf einem
Vulkan
[Applaus]
wie wahnsinnig muss man eigentlich sein
wenn man Bürgerinnen und Bürger wenn man
Europäerinnen und Europäer und nicht
zuletzt die Ukrainer selbst auf diese
Weise eine tödlichen und
unverantwortbaren Risiko aussetzt
[Applaus]
vor kurzem hat die Gesellschaft für
Informatik in einem offenen Brief vor
einem Atomkrieg aus Versehen gewarnt
in einer Krisensituation wie im
Augenblick
könnten sich die Optik
computergestützten früher waren Systeme
selbstständig machen
das ist auch ohne Krise schon mehrfach
fast passiert
die früh warensysteme sollen einen
atomaren Überraschungsangriff erkennen
die vorwandzeiten sind aber unterdessen
so kurz dass sowohl die Rechner die auch
die Menschen überfordert sind und dabei
geht es um Minuten manchmal Sekunden
vor allem auch die angeheizte Eskalation
hält die Gesellschaft für Informatik für
hochgefährlich
ein Atomkrieg aus Versehen wird
wahrscheinlicher durch Eskalation
je länger sich der Krieg hinzieht und je
mehr eskaliert wird summieren sich die
Möglichkeiten dass ein Atomkrieg
ausbricht ohne dass es jemand will
das gegenseitige gemisstrauen und der
Dauerstress tragen dazu bei
überhaupt ist eine Eskalation oder ist
jede Eskalation eine Weltkriegs unter
druckkriegsgefahr
achillary Waffen Schützenpanzer
Kampfpanzer bald auch Kampfjets
Langstreckenraketen Kriegsschiffe
U-Boote und so weiter und so weiter
das ist zugleich ein austesten wann die
rote Linie überschritten wird und sich
der Krieg auf Europa und vielleicht die
Welt ausweitet
und niemand weiß wo die rote Linie ist
die westliche Politik scheint es aber
herausfinden zu wollen
sie testet aus was passiert wenn man die
rote Linie überschreitet
hat sich Frau baerbock deshalb neulich
begeistert die Atombunker angeschaut die
sich unter Helsinki befinden
wird deshalb bedauert
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wird deshalb bedauert dass Deutschland
nicht ebenso schöne Bunker hat
auch das zeigt wie ich meine die
Verantwortungslosigkeit der
Politikerinnen und Politiker
es kann ja sein dass man einen Atomkrieg
im Atom im Atom im Bunker überleben kann
aber wenn man daraus kriegt kann man
nicht weiterleben
es geht nicht
mein Appell an alle politischen
Ignoranten und Liebhaber von atombunkern
nehmt euch bitte die Zeit studiert die
aktuellen wissenschaftlichen Studien zu
den Folgen eines Atomkriegs
auch sogenannte Kleine nuklear Kriege
werden zu einer Verfinsterung der
Erdatmosphäre führen die man nuklearen
Internet
wer die Atombunker verlassen hat der
findet nichts mehr zu essen das Klima
übrigens kaputt
Ärzte die helfen könnten sind auch keine
Daten
ich will abschließen
ich schließe ab indem ich die
entscheidende Frage stelle wie kann der
völkerrechtswidrig ja gerade zu
kriminell begonnene Ukraine Krieg
wie können wir diesen Menschen dort
helfen
um diese Frage zu beantworten müssen wir
zunächst einmal wissen was wirklich und
absolut falsch ist
falsch ist es auf jeden Fall den Krieg
mit Zielsetzungen fortzusetzen die
unklar verschwommen und unrealistisch
sind
[Applaus]
falsch ist es unter solchen
Voraussetzungen Öl ins Feuer zu gießen
indem man zu einer mörderischen
Eskalation beiträgt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
falsch ist es das sinnlose Sterben zu
verlängern indem man jede Menge
tötungsgeräte und Mordwerkzeuge schickt
[Applaus]
falsch ist es aber vor allem und darauf
kommt es mir ganz besonders an
ein für die Ukrainerinnen Ukrainer für
die deutschen und Europäer ja für die
Menschen der ganzen Welt
untragbares Risiko zu produzieren
Weltkrieg wäre Völkermord
Atomkrieg wäre Völkermord
auf keinen Fall darf die Hilfe die wir
den Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainern anbieten
ein schlimmeres Desaster anrichten als
dasjenige das sowieso schon da ist
eine Not eine Notoperation darf nicht
den Patienten töten oder gar das
Operationsteam und die Klinik in die
Luft jagen
[Applaus]
so und wenn so viel falsch ist das wäre
dann richtig
das ist eigentlich gesunder
Menschenverstand wenn man sagt zunächst
soll man mit den töten aufhören das
heißt also wir brauchen einen
Waffenstillstand
anschließend oder gleichzeitig brauchen
wir Friedensverhandlungen
warum denn sollte es so ganz unmöglich
sein
dass eine groß angelegte internationale
Friedensinitiative zu einem Erfolg führt
und zwar jetzt
[Applaus]
auch wenn niemand prophezeihen kann was
bei solchen Verhandlungen herauskommt
besser als ein weltkrieg oder eine
atomare Katastrophe wird es mit
Sicherheit sein
[Applaus]
wir brauchen endlich den Mut es mit dem
Frieden zu versuchen
für das Leben
für die Schonung dieses Planeten
für ein gemeinsames Haus Europa
endlich Frieden schaffen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es ist wichtig dass heute so viele
Menschen hier sind um zu demonstrieren
für ein Ende des fürchterlichen Krieges
in der Ukraine für ein Ende der
Kriegsrhetorik in Deutschland für einen
Ausstieg aus der Gewaltspirale und der
militärischen Eskalation für eine
politische Lösung des militärisch
festgefahrenen Krieges und für den
baldigen Beginn von Verhandlungen
[Applaus]
bei allen Meinungsunterschieden ist da
ein gemeinsames Ziel den Frieden in der
Ukraine baldmöglichst wieder
herzustellen es ist naiv zu glauben man
könne Russland militärisch ohne
nukleakrieg besiegen es ist naiv zu
glauben man können nur über
Waffenlieferungen zum Frieden kommen und
es ist naiv zu glauben dass wir mit
unseren Waffenlieferungen die Lage die
militärische Lage verändern
weit über 200.000 Soldatinnen und
Soldaten
sind gefallen
50.000 Unbeteiligte Zivilpersonen sind
ums Leben gekommen über 8 Millionen
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer sind auf der
Flucht
der von Russland ausgelöste
völkerrechtswidrige Angriffskrieg ist
nach einem Jahr zu einem militärisch
gesprochen abnutzungskrieg geworden
Stichwort werden 1916
damals wurde vor exerziert was
militärische Abnutzung bedeutet damals
starben fast eine Million junger
Franzosen und deutscher sinnlos und für
nichts
Abnutzung bedeutet das ist keine
vernünftige militärische Lösung mehr
gibt das sagt auch der
us-generalstaatschef mag milay und
dieser Einschätzung teilt auch die
renommierte RAND Corporation
der Westen liefert trotzdem weiter trotz
des militärischen sinnlosen Sterbens in
der Ukraine Waffen heute Panzer morgen
Kampfhubschrauber Kampfflugzeuge und
Raketen
dies wird auch von vielen deutschen
Politikern lauthals gefordert ohne zu
bedenken dass dadurch der Krieg unter
Einbeziehung russischen Territoriums
ausgeweitet wird
das alles wird getan ohne Klarheit
darüber zu haben was wir konkret mit den
Waffenlieferungen erreichen wollen
geht es darum Russland zu besiegen wie
manche fordern geht es um die
Rückeroberung von Krim und dombas geht
es darum die Ukraine lediglich zu
stabilisieren um ihre
Verhandlungsposition zu stärken versteht
wir liefern seit Monaten nur Waffen und
es fällt uns nicht viel mehr ein
wir tun das alles ohne jede realistische
lösungsperspektive ohne eine
überzeugende Strategie der
Konfliktlösung und ohne ein politisches
Konzept streng genommen ist das
Militarismus pur weil man militärische
Hilfeleistungen nicht an realistische
politische Ziele koppelt
[Applaus]
es muss mit Blick auf die militärische
Gesamtlage klar gesagt werden die
Lieferungen von Waffen können den
Ukrainern leider nicht helfen diesen
Krieg zu gewinnen sie drehen die
militärische partsituationen nicht um
diese kann auf militärischem Wege allein
nicht aufgelöst werden wir haben einen
Stellungskrieg bei der Seiten im Osten
und Dauerbeschuss der Infrastruktur in
der gesamten Ukraine durch Russland
russland hat leider die militärische
eskalationsdominanz angefangen bei der
Mobilisierung bis hin zum Einsatz von
Nuklearwaffen das ist nicht nur für die
Ukraine sondern für uns alle eine
existenzielle Gefahr die man nicht
unterschätzen sollte ich will hier keine
Angst verbreiten aber einige oder sehr
viele hierzulande machen es sich sehr
leicht wenn sie sagen dass eine
Atommacht wenn sie militärisch keinen
Erfolg hat schon nicht zu Nuklearwaffen
greifen wird das hätten die Amerikaner
in Vietnam oder Afghanistan auch nicht
gemacht diese Vergleiche hinken ganz
gewaltig weil die Schwarzmeerregion für
Russland etwa die gleiche strategische
Bedeutung hat wie die Karibik für die
USA oder das Südchinesische Meer für
China
die Russen können da nicht einfach nach
Hause gehen wie der Westen in
Afghanistan im Irak in Syrien oder in
Libyen
das alles ist ähnlich das alles ist
ähnlich wie die Kubakrise 1962
für die USA war es damals auch nicht
möglich
sowjetischen Einfluss in der Karibik
zuzustimmen und ähnlich wie in der
Kubakrise kommen wir aus dem Ukraine
Krieg durch nur durch besonnenes
politisches Handeln durch Verhandlungen
und Kompromisse heraus
Russland wird auch nach dem Ukraine
Krieg ein Machtfaktor in Europa bleiben
und es wird auch in Zukunft keine
tragfähige europäische Friedensordnung
geben ohne Russland weil Russland eben
von der Landkarte nicht verschwinden
kann
[Applaus]
trotz aller Gegensätze hier bringt
Säbelrasseln sehr wenig wenn es nicht
mit einem klugen und besonnenen
politischen Vorgehen verknüpft wird
deshalb muss Politik nach anderen Wegen
suchen um den Weltfrieden nicht zu
gefährden sind jetzt mehr Diplomatie und
Interessenausgleich notwendig und
weniger Kriegsrhetorik und eine
öffentlich zur Schau gestellte
haltungsdiplomatie
Verhandlungen sind jetzt der einzig
mögliche Weg zu einer Lösung zu kommen
ein weiter so bedeutet den sinnlosen
Verschleiß von Menschenleben
die Mehrheit der Deutschen ist eindeutig
gegen die Ausweitung von
Waffenlieferungen und für Verhandlungen
[Musik]
das muss sich in der deutschen Politik
auch wieder spiegeln denn sie sind ja
Vertreter des Volkes
[Applaus]
militärische Operationen und
Waffenlieferungen müssen immer an den
Versuch gekoppelt bleiben politische
Lösungen herbeizuführen und das
Grundgesetz unsere Verfassung kennt
zudem das sogenannte Friedensgebot
unsere Verfassung fordert dazu auf
Frieden zu bewahren und oder
baldmöglichst
[Applaus]
eine lange vordauer des Ukraine Krieges
ist weder im Deutschen noch im
europäischen Interesse
lösungsorientiertes außenpolitisches
Handeln braucht daher eine andere
Gewichtung sie muss ihre Hauptaufgabe
wieder ins in den Blick nehmen
Diplomatie Interessenausgleich
Verständigung und Konfliktbewältigung
[Applaus]
wir helfen der Ukraine wir haben
Mitverantwortung für die Ukraine aber
wir müssen auch Mitsprache beanspruchen
daher muss auf politischer Ebene mehr
miteinander gesprochen werden
die deutsche und die französische
Regierung sollten endlich initiativ
werden in Richtung auf einen
Waffenstillstand und anschließende
Verhandlungen
und wo und wo steht Europa der Ukraine
Krieg ist doch ein genuin europäisches
Thema wieso kommen die
Friedensinitiativen nicht von der EU
sondern aus Brasilien und China
[Applaus]
vom Ukraine Krieg ist besonders Europa
als Schlachtfeld dieses Krieges und als
potentieller
hauptkriegsschauplatz eines großen
Krieges betroffen gerade deswegen fehlt
mir die politische Gestaltungskraft
Europas Deutschland und Europa dürfen
nicht länger Objekt und Spielball sein
wollen in einem Stellvertreter Krieg mit
Russland der Gefahr läuft um China
ausgeweitet zu werden
europa muss endlich ein
interessengeleiteter strategischer
Akteur werden
und wir brauchen dringend oberhalb der
geberkonferenzen für Waffenlieferungen
eine politisch strategische Ebene unter
Einbeziehung von wichtigen Ländern
dieser Welt
wir brauchen endlich einen politisch
abgestimmten Plan der die Frage
beantwortet wie alle aus diesem Krieg
herauskommen und die zentrale politische
Perspektive muss es sein den Krieg zu
beenden und endlich realistische Wege
zum Frieden zu finden ich danke Ihnen
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde Liebe
Friedensfreunde ich bin so froh dass ihr
alle hier heute gekommen seid und ich
weiß dass auch viele tausende unsere
Kundgebung an den verschiedenen
Livestreams mitverfolgen ich denke heute
kann man sehen wie viele wir sind und
von jetzt an werden wir unsere Stimme so
laut erheben dass sie nicht mehr
übergangen werden kann
wenn liebe Freundinnen und Freunde wir
sind nicht nur viele wir fangen jetzt
auch an uns zu organisieren weil
Deutschland braucht endlich wieder eine
wirklich starke Friedensbewegung
ihr habt ja alle verfolgt was passiert
ist als Alice Schwarzer und ich
gemeinsam mit 69 erst unterzeichnen
unser Manifest für Frieden
veröffentlicht haben da ist in Teilen
der politischen und medialen
Öffentlichkeit Deutschlands eine
regelrechte Hysterie ausgebrochen
[Musik]
was hat man uns nicht alles unterstellt
was hat man uns nicht alles vorgeworfen
uns und damit stellvertretend natürlich
auch den über 600.000 Unterzeichnern
unseres Manifests wir seien zynisch
gewissenlos am moralisch Handlanger
Putins womöglich sogar von Putin bezahlt
und trotzdem haben sich die Menschen
nicht abhalten lassen sie haben unser
Manifest unterzeichnet jeden Tag werden
es mehr die das Manifest unterzeichnen
und da muss ich ja auch noch mal sagen
das ist großartig von euch allen ein
herzliches Dankeschön
ich meine die Kampagne gegen uns
sie gipfelte darin dass man versucht hat
uns in die Nähe der extremen Rechten
zurück Rücken daran sieht man wie krank
die Diskussion in Deutschland inzwischen
ist seit wann ist der Ruf nach Frieden
der Ruf nach Diplomatie und
Verhandlungen rechts und
kriegsbesoffenheit ist dann wohl links
einige haben ja offenbar völlig ihren
politischen Kompass verloren
und ich sage ja auch noch mal in aller
Deutlichkeit nur um die alle
abzuschrecken die das schon wieder
überall verbreiten wollen weil es sich
eigentlich von selbst versteht aber ich
sage es trotzdem noch mal
selbstverständlich haben Neonazis und
Reichsbürger die in der Tradition von
Regie entstehen die für die schlimmsten
Weltkriege der Menschheitsgeschichte
Verantwortung tragen auf unserer
Friedenskundgebung nicht zu suchen das
versteht sich aber wohl von selbst
dachte ich
[Applaus]
aber genauso sage ich auch jeder der
ehrlichen Herzens mit uns für Frieden
und für Verhandlungen demonstrieren will
ist hier willkommen und aus soll man
nicht so eine dumme Debatte machen es
nervt mich auf welchem Niveau in
Deutschland inzwischen diskutiert wird
es ist wirklich unsäglich
[Applaus]
und ich finde auch auch das möchte ich
hier noch mal sagen wenn wir schon über
rechtsoffenheit reden das ist ja ein
Begriff der ganz oft gefallen ist im
Vorfeld der Kundgebung wenn wir schon
über rechtsoffenheit reden dann sollen
sich die kriegstrommel doch verdammt
noch mal an ihre eigene Nase fassen
Leute die keine Scham haben sich mit
anderen zu verbünden die ganz echte
Nazis für ihre nicht denke da z.B an den
früheren rüppelbotschafter und hatten
Vize-Außenminister der Ukraine Herr
Melnik der macht gar keinen Hehl daraus
[Applaus]
mehlig und auch andere Größen dieses
Landes machen doch gar keinen Hehl
daraus dass sie beispielsweise in dem
nazi-kollaborateur Stefan bandera einen
nationalen Heron sehen und ich erinnere
daran bei derer der Antisemit ist mit
verantwortlich für die Ermordung von
tausenden Juden Polen und Russen und
dieser Mann wird von Melnik und anderen
verehrt und unsere kriegstromler machen
sich mit denen Gemeinden und erzählen
uns etwas über querfreund und rechts
Offenheit was ist das für eine verlogene
Debatte das möchte ich auch noch mal
deutlich sagen
aber das hysterische Gebrüll das ist
tierische Gebrüll in Teilen der Politik
und der Medien zeigt natürlich auch
sie haben wirklich Angst vor uns sie
haben Angst vor einer neuen
Friedensbewegung und ich finde da haben
sie auch Grund dafür sie haben nämlich
Angst dass sie ihre Politik nicht mehr
ohne weiteres so fortsetzen können und
ich sage Ihnen ja genau deshalb sind wir
hier damit sie diese Politik nicht
fortsetzen können also bitte schön wenn
sie Angst haben das ist ein Kompliment
für uns alle
[Applaus]
es geht um viel
es geht um viel es geht zum einen darum
dass furchtbare Leid und das Sterben an
der Ukraine zu beenden es geht darum
Russland einfach handlungsangebot zu
unterbreiten statt einen endlosen
abnutzungskrieg mit immer neuen Waffen
zu munitionieren ich meine man muss sich
das mal vorstellen das Weiße Haus so
beiden hat mit
Rüstungskonzernen über viele Jahre
Verträge abgeschlossen also für viele
Jahre Verträge abgeschlossen dass die
die Ukraine mit Waffen beliefern für
viele Jahre soll die Kriegsmaschine die
munitioniert werden damit ihr nicht die
Waffen ausgehen was ist das für eine
wahnsinnige und zynische Politik und die
stellen sich dann auch noch hin und
sagen das sei Solidarität mit der
Ukraine was ist das für eine Lüge das
ist doch keine Solidarität das ist das
genaue Gegenteil dessen
[Applaus]
den Solidarität das ist doch völlig klar
Solidarität wäre alles dafür zu tun das
Sterben zu beenden Solidarität heißt
Leben retten und nicht Leben zerstören
Solidarität heißt sich für den Frieden
zu engagieren und nicht für den Krieg
und dafür braucht man keine Panzer dafür
braucht man Diplomatie Verhandlungen und
Kompromissbereitschaft von beiden Seiten
das braucht man dafür das ist
solidarisch
[Applaus]
und ja natürlich das sage ich ja auch
selbstverständlich geht diese Appell
auch an den russischen Präsidenten
natürlich muss auch Putin bereit sein zu
Verhandlungen und Kompromissen die
Ukraine darf kein russisches Protektorat
werden aber nach allen Berichten die wir
über die Friedensverhandlungen im
Frühjahr haben und damals hatte sich der
damalige israelische Ministerpräsident
Bennet engagiert und auch die türkische
Regierung nach allen Berichten über die
Verhandlungen damals muss man sagen die
sind offensichtlich damals nicht an der
russischen Seite gescheitert und auch
das gehört zur Wahrheit finde ich dazu
es geht also darum das Sterben in der
Ukraine zu beenden aber es geht auch um
mehr das ist ja hier schon angesprochen
worden es geht auch darum das Risiko
einer Ausweitung dieses Krieges auf ganz
Europa womöglich auf die ganze Welt
dieses Risiko zu bannen und es ist
verdammt groß dieses Risiko wir haben
alle gesehen der Einschlag einer
ukrainischen Rakete in Polen damals die
er zunächst als russische Rakete
hingestellt wurde der hat dazu geführt
dass die ersten verrückten tatsächlich
schon gefordert haben der Bündnisfall
müsse jetzt eintreten und wir alle
wissen doch es kann ja tatsächlich mal
eine russische Rakete sogar aus Versehen
die jenseits der Ukraine einschlagen und
was passiert dann haben wir dann den
Bündnisfall haben wir dann den Weltkrieg
das heißt mit jedem Tag an dem dieser
Krieg verändert wird und mit jeder
tödlichen Waffe die wir da weiter
zusätzliche dieses Pulverfass liefern
wächst die Gefahr für einen großen Krieg
in ganz Europa und womöglich in der
ganzen Welt und auch das müssen wir
unbedingt stoppen auch da gegen stehen
wir heute hier weil das ist eine
unverantwortliche Entwicklung die
unbedingt aufhören muss
[Applaus]
oder erzählt man uns ja das sei doch
putinpropaganda nein liebe Leute auch
der
UN-Generalsekretär guterisch hat vor
kurzem sehr deutlich davor gewarnt dass
die Welt gerade dabei ist mit sehenden
Augen mit weit geöffnetem Augen in einen
großen Krieg hineinzugehen ist guterisch
auch ein putinpropagandist mein Gott die
haben wir nur die Augen so schließen wie
kann man nur so kriegsbesoffen sein dass
man diese Gefahr nicht sieht das ist
doch Wahnsinn das zu verantworten und
[Applaus]
oder meinen einige vielleicht auch diese
Gefahr die müssen wir heldenhaft in Kauf
nehmen weil wir ja für das Gute kämpfen
und auf der richtigen Seite der
Geschichte steht und denen die das sagen
möchte ich deutlich entgegnen nein wer
die Gefahr eines nuklearen Entfernung
der steht nicht auf der richtigen Seite
der Geschichte und wer nicht alles in
seiner Macht stehende tut um die Gefahr
einer solchen Eskalation zu bannen der
kämpft auch nicht für das Gute sondern
der ist verantwortungslos
[Applaus]
die atomkriegsuhr
die atomkriegsuhr steht aktuell bei 90
Sekunden vor 12 die Wissenschaftler die
diese ur betreuen haben sie vor kurzem
noch einmal nach vorne gestellt
interessiert das die Bundesregierung
überhaupt nicht
noch nie noch nicht mal im Kalten Krieg
stand die Welt so nah an der Schwelle
eines atomaren Infernos und auch deshalb
sind wir heute hier denn das darf nicht
weitergehen dieser Atomuhr muss wieder
zurück verdammt noch mal sie muss weiter
weg von 12 Uhr und nicht immer näher
dran kommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich kann mich noch gut an meine Kindheit
und Jugend erinnern das waren die 80er
Jahre des 20 Jahrhunderts das war die
Zeit wo über
raketenstationierungen in Deutschland
diskutiert wurde und weltweit über
sternkriegsprogramme ich bin
aufgewachsen mit der Angst vor einem
großen Krieg mit der Angst vor einem
Atompilz über Berlin
und ich kann mich noch gut erinnern wie
dankbar ich war als dann mit Michael
Gorbatschow eine neue Zeit begann eine
Zeit der abrüstungsgespräche und
Abrüstungsverträge und das war eine Zeit
wo man das Gefühl hatte ja jetzt beginnt
ein neues Zeitalter ein Zeitalter der
Abrüstung der Zusammenarbeit und der
gemeinsamen Sicherheit
ich gebe zu ich hatte in den Jahren
danach fast vergessen wie es sich
anfühlt wenn man Angst hat vor Krieg
heute weiß ich es wieder
heute 30 Jahre nach Gorbatschow hat
Putin mit dem staatabkommen gerade den
letzten noch gültigen Abrüstungsvertrag
auf Eis gelegt das hat er getan nachdem
die USA zuvor den ABM-Vertrag den
einenf-vertrag und das Open sky-abkommen
aufgekündigt hatten heute redet niemand
mehr von Abrüstung heute wird
aufgerüstet was das Zeug hält und die
Atomwaffenarsenale werden modernisiert
heute wollen Politiker unseres Landes
das Gorbatschow seine Wiedervereinigung
verdankt Russland ruinieren heute sollen
russisch sollen deutsche Kampfpanzer
wieder auf russische Soldaten schießen
und zumindest Melnik ist sich sicher
dass bald auch Kampfjets geliefert
werden liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
diesen Wahnsinn müssen wir Stopp en
deshalb sind wir heute hier
[Applaus]
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde wir leben
ja in einer orwelschen Welt was erzählt
man uns da eigentlich für Geschichten
Panzer schaffen Frieden was wenn retten
Menschen leben und der ukrainische
oligarchenkapitalismus der genauso
korrupt ist wie der russische kämpft
angeblich für unsere Freiheit und unsere
Demokratie
schon George Orwell wusste
wenn alle die verbreitete Lüge glaubten
dann ging die Lüge in die Geschichte ein
und wurde zur Wahrheit und deswegen
sagen wir deutlich wir glauben eure
Lügen nicht mehr wir wissen dass Waffen
töten und Panzer dazu da sind Krieg zu
führen
[Applaus]
und wir wissen auch
wir wissen auch dass unsere Freiheit
nicht in der Ukraine verteidigt wird
genauso wenig wie vorher am Hindukusch
und es geht auch nicht
[Applaus]
und es geht auch nicht um Heere Werte in
diesem Krieg sondern um die NATO und den
Umfang der amerikanischen Einflusszone
und deshalb sind wir hier damit dieses
sinnlose sterben aufhört und wir sind
auch deshalb hier weil wir uns von der
deutschen Regierung nicht vertreten
fühlen
[Applaus]
wir fühlen uns nicht vertreten von einer
grünen Außenministerin die wie
ein von einer grünen Außenministerin die
wie ein Elefant im Porzellanladen über
das internationale parketttrampelt und
ihre öffentlichen Äußerungen so wenig im
Griff hat dass sie mal eben aus Versehen
Russland den Krieg erklärt nein von Frau
Berber fühlen wir uns nicht vertreten
[Applaus]
und wir fühlen uns auch nicht vertreten
von Panzer Toni und den ganzen grünen
Waffen Narren die den Eindruck erwecken
sie würden am liebsten gleich selbst mit
geladenem Rohr im Leopard gehen Russland
Rollen was ist das für eine Debatte die
da geführt wird Petra Kelly würde sich
mit Grausen von dieser Partei abwenden
das muss man ja auch mal deutlich sagen
[Applaus]
und liebe Freunde und Freunde wir fühlen
uns auch nicht vertreten von einer
rüstungslobbyisten Strack Zimmermann der
die Geschäftsbilanz
[Applaus]
der die Geschäftsbilanz von Rheinmetall
und Co offensichtlich mehr am Herzen
liegt als das Schicksal der Menschen in
der Ukraine oder gar der Weltfrieden
nein von dieser Frau und von einer FDP
wo die strafzimmermanns den Ton angeben
fühlen wir uns nicht vertreten
[Applaus]
aber wir fühlen uns auch nicht vertreten
von einem Kanzler der zwar zunächst
immer zögert und für Bedachtsamkeit und
Vorsicht wirbt aber dann trotzdem
regelmäßig vor den kriegstromlern in
seiner Koalition einknickt und eine rote
Linie nach der nächsten überschreite
nein Herr Scholz auch von ihnen fühlen
wir uns nicht vertreten weil das ist
eine fatale Politik
[Applaus]
wir wollen nicht
wir wollen nicht das mit deutschen
Panzern auf die Urenkel jener russischen
Frauen und Männer geschossen wird deren
Urgroßeltern tatsächlich von der mehr
macht auch bestialische Weise
millionenfach sie ermordet wurden wir
wollen nicht dass auf deren Urenkel
wieder geschossen wird mit deutschen
Waffen auch deshalb sind wir hier weil
das ist wirklich völlig geschichts
vergessen haben die denn überhaupt nicht
mehr im Kopf was deutsche Geschichte mal
war
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Entschuldigung hier ist ein
Rettungseinsatz bitte Platz machen dass
der durchkommt das ist ganz wichtig
möchte ich nur zwischendurch sagen und
wir liebe Freunde und Freunde wir wollen
auch nicht auch deshalb sind wir hier
das Deutschland sich immer weiter in
diesen Krieg hineinziehen lässt so lange
bis der Krieg möglicherweise hier ist
das will wir wollen wir auf gar keinen
Fall und dagegen wären wir uns und
deswegen sind wir hier auch so zahlreich
nein Schluss wieder mit dem Krieg
[Applaus]
wir halten es
wir halten es mit der großen
pazifistischen Schriftstellerin Bertha
von Suttner die einmal geschrieben hat
keinen vernünftigen Menschen wird es
einfallen
Tintenflecken mit Tinte
Ölflecken mit Öl wegwaschen zu wollen
nur Blut das soll immer wieder mit Blut
ausgewaschen werden nein liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde das wollen wir
nicht lasst uns das Blut vergießen
stoppen wir stehen auf für Frieden und
gegen den Krieg wir sind da und wir
werden nicht mehr verschwinden lasst uns
heute den Startschuss für eine neue
starke Friedensbewegung in Deutschland
geben ganz herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
bisher ist es schade es ist wirklich
schade dass ihr nicht alle hier stehen
könnt weil das ist ein Bild der Hoffnung
was ich hier sehe ja die die Medien
haben wir in den letzten zwei Wochen
gemeldet häkelt was ist das und so
weiter Rechte
Schlägertrupps und so dass Menschen
manche Menschen Angst hatten zu kommen
und dabei ist es ein reines Vergnügen
also eure Fahnen um die ganze Stimmung
hier also wenn wir das so weitermachen
dann kriegen wir wieder ein bisschen
Menschlichkeit in die Politik ja
[Applaus]
ich habe in den vergangenen Monaten sehr
viel über Panzer gelernt
und zwar von Redakteuren die in der
Regel Panzer nur aus Computerspielen
können die beschreiben fasziniert die
Funktion ja sogar das Design von Panzern
das kennen Sie auch nur aus dem
Computerspiel nur eines hat mir bisher
gefehlt bei diesem berichten die
Menschen
genauer gesagt die Leichen denn Panzer
sind tötungsinstrumente tödlich für alle
tödlich für die drin sitzen wenn sie
angegriffen werden dann verbrennen sie
und tödlich für die die in Schussweite
geraten
wofür also riskieren diese Menschen ihr
Leben
letztendlich geht es ja in jedem Krieg
egal welche Seite um Interessen und
macht um Freunde und Geopolitik
für die Menschen aber
liebe Freunde und Freundinnen
Freundinnen und Freunde für die Menschen
geht es um ihr Leben darum sind wir hier
weil für uns Krieg keine computerspiele
sind sondern eine sehr ernste tödliche
Sache
deshalb
war es durchaus richtig den von Russland
brutal überfallenen Ukrainern mit Waffen
zur Seite zu stehen zunächst um sich zu
verteidigen
und genau deshalb ist es heute richtig
nach einem Jahr tot und Verwüstung und
nachdem das Ziel dieses
Krieges zu fragen und nach seiner
Verhältnismäßigkeit
ist das Ziel der Rückzug der Russen
aus den seit dem 24 Februar 22
besetzten Gebieten
das wäre legitim und durchaus in
Verhandlungen von beiden Seiten und mit
Kompromissen zu erreichen oder ist das
Ziel nicht nur die Schwächung sondern
die Vernichtung von Russlands das wäre
weder legitim noch realistisch was kann
die große Atom macht
man kann die große Atom macht nicht
besiegen
sollte man das ernsthaft versuchen
könnte es das Ende unserer Welt bedeuten
wir befinden uns jetzt
in einem sogenannten
abnutzungskrieg man stellte sich nur mal
das Wort vor es sollte eigentlich das
Unwort des Jahres werden abnutzungskrieg
[Applaus]
wer wird hier abgenutzt
die Waffen werden abgenutzt das ist
natürlich zur großen Freude der
Waffenindustrie die nachliefern wird
aber es werden die Menschen abgenutzt
das ist ja schon ein paar der Unmensch
so ein Krieg in diesem Krieg kann der
Gegner nicht besiegt werden sondern nur
geschwächt darum heißt der
abnutzungskrieg stimmt was mit dem
metronomie noch näher also
der erste Schritt das haben wir jetzt in
diesem Monaten erlebt eines
abnutzungskrieges war die psychologische
Vergiftung des gesellschaftlichen Klimas
das führen
[Applaus]
das Führen eines Gut und Böse Denkens
als gäbe es nur die guten und nur die
bösen wie bei Orell
dieses Denken
dämonisiert die Gegner
und entmenschlich sie
darum redet Russland heute nur von Nazis
in der Ukraine und die Ukraine von
Teufeln
den Menschen bringen nicht Menschen um
sondern nur Unmenschen da fängt es an
der logische
wie nett ist das ein Beifall
der logische zweite Krieg der logische
zweite Schritt ist die Akzeptanz des
Krieges wie kann es sein wie können wir
in diese Barbarei zurückfallen
von Stellungskämpfen ist inzwischen
sogar die Rede Stellungskämpfe
das habe ich das letzte mal von meinem
Großvater in den 50er Jahren gehört der
ist im Ersten Weltkrieg in das Massaker
von Werder das hatte generalfahrt eben
schon erwähnt geraten
der oberarmten sich die französischen
und die deutschen Soldaten am 24
September kamen
geweint haben sich umarmt und ab dem 25
haben sie sich wieder erschlagen erwirkt
erstochen
gestochen und erschossen
dass meine Lieben ist die wahre
Zeitenwende die Zeitenwende ist dass das
Wort Pazifist zu einem Schimpfwort
geworden ist und zwar von links man
stellt sich das mal vor
in der Ukraine führen die beiden
Weltmächte Russland und Amerika ein
Stellvertreter Krieg das weiß inzwischen
doch glaube ich jeder aber vor ein paar
Monaten bin ich mir einen Hofreiter noch
verlacht worden als ich das im Fernsehen
sagte und hat er mich einen
paranoika oder
wahnhafte
wadenhafte Vorstellungen genannt also
das ist ja in diesem in dieser ganzen
gesellschaftlichen Debatte die bisher
nicht stattgefunden hat die jetzt jetzt
fängt das Gespräch an jetzt zwingt ihr
mit diesem massenhaften auftreter
Auftreten die Medien und die Politik
endlich euch zuzuhören
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das wird ja nicht zugegeben dass es sich
hier um einen Stellvertreterkrieg bisher
wurde das nicht so gegeben der beiden
Weltmächte handelt Russland und Amerika
krachen auf dem Terran der Ukraine
zusammen und wer bezahlt den Preis die
Ukraine
sie sterben jeden Tag zu Hunderten und
ihr Landwirt verwüstet zurückbleiben und
ich muss Ihnen sagen ich finde es
wirklich verbrecherisch der Ukraine
einzureden sie könne Russland besiegen
die Ukraine
konnte und kann natürlich in einzelnen
Schlachten
Siegen aber nicht darüber hinaus sie
kann nicht Russland in die Knie zwingen
aber was tut die deutsche
Außenministerin die ja von Beruf
eine
ich sehe schon ich sehe schon die
Nennung des Namens von Annalena bärbock
ist hier eine sichere Bank
[Musik]
also
ein eine
Außenminister soll ich doch ein paar
Worte sagen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bitte lassen Sie mich noch ein paar
Worte sagen
also eine Außenministerin ist von Beruf
Diplomat und zwar der erste Diplomat des
Landes was aber tut diese
Außenministerin sie führt in dieser
brandgefährlichen Situation
anscheinend noch nicht einmal Gespräche
mit Russland also man kann nur hoffen
dass sie das heimlich und hinter
verschlossener Türe tut aber es sieht
nicht so aus denn mit Russland reden ist
ja die einzige Möglichkeit diesen Krieg
zu beenden nach einem Jahr um unsere
alle Experten er ist militärisch nicht
zu gewinnen
und dann muss man eben mit einer reden
aber die Außenministerin sagt mit so
einem Verbrecher wie Putin dürfe man
nicht verhandeln
und sie hat sogar von einem Krieg gegen
Russland geredet das hat sie inzwischen
sagt sie nicht so gemeint aber das ist
schon erstaunlich wenn eine
Außenministerin Dinge sagt die sie gar
nicht so meint
und ich frage Sie wo soll das enden
sie sind doch Feministin
diesen Satz habe ich manchmal zu hören
bekommen in der letzten Zeit warum
kümmern sie sich dann jetzt um den Krieg
meine Lieben eben weil ich Feministin
bin denn Krieg ist der ist ja auch der
Gipfel des männlichkeitswagens der Weg
von der Gewalt
der Weg von der Gewalt
der Weg von der Gewalt im Ehebett zur
Gewalt an der Front ist nicht weit
und wer nicht begeistert mit marschiert
ist ein Weichei das hat man ja auch mal
von Zeus gesagt ich kann nur hoffen dass
man das weiterhin zurecht von ihm sagt
also wer nicht mit marschiert ist
weiblich die Gewalt war und ist für
unabhängige Frauenrechtlerinnen bitte
ich betone das Wort unabhängig also ein
zentrales Thema und der Gipfel der
Gewalt ist der Krieg ich bin stolz
darauf in einer feministischen Tradition
zu stehen für die kriege immer schon ein
Verbrechen waren
Bertha von Suttner
Bertha von Suttner die Initiatorin des
Nobelpreises für den Frieden war nicht
zufällig eine aktive frauenrechterin und
die quasi einzigen Stimmen die sich 1940
in der Kriegs Euphorie in der das ganze
Land versunken war gegen den Krieg
gestellt haben waren fast ausschließlich
wann soll es sich glauben Feministinnen
ja da ist der
ein bisschen zaghafter aber es ist in
der Tat
kein Zufall dass eine Feministinnen
Feministin seit Beginn dieses Krieges an
der Front des Prozesses ist
man sollte ihn vielleicht öfter zu hören
ja sie sind abnutzungskrieg den ich eben
schon erwähnte kann niemand gewinnen und
das wissen auch alle schon irgendwie im
November letzten Jahres sprach der eben
schon erwähnte oberste Militär
von einer partysituation und erfordert
dringend Verhandlungen
ein abnutzungskrieg würde bedeuten
jahrelanges weiteres Elend sterben und
Zerstörung und am Ende dieses
abnutzungskrieges werden was steht an
eines abnutzungskrieges Treiber der
seraten Verhandlungen
Verhandlungen also es ist nicht zu
fassen
warum nicht jetzt Verhandlungen geführt
werden jeder weiß
dass nur Verhandlung
das nur Verhandlungen diesen Krieg zu
Ende bringen werden nun reden die ganz
schlauen von naja wird wohl
verabredennutzungskrieg von etwa drei
Jahren werden drei Jahre
drei Jahre wo wir schon im ersten Jahr
eine viertel Millionen Tote haben
vergewaltigte Frauen traumatisierte
Kinder eine schwere Erschütterung
Europas eine ökonomische Krise
ganz zu schweigen von der Lage des
globalen Südens
90%
unserer Weltbevölkerung lebt im globalen
Süden
und den geht es jetzt noch schlechter
als vorher die Hungerkrisen steigen
wegen dieses Krieges und in diesen bei
diesen 90% der Menschheit
ist eine überwältigende Mehrheit
gegen diesen Krieg und sehr viele sind
auch auf der Seite Russlands das ist die
andere Seite des Globus
warum also
hören die Militärs des Westens nicht
aufzuwachen
und was tun die Politiker sie machen
einfach weiter
sie Pokern mit unserer leben
wird gut
wird Putin oder wird er nicht man weiß
es nicht auch welcher Putin soll ja auch
ja um Gottes Willen wir haben doch
gesehen dass Putin ernst macht also
einmarschiert ist ich gehöre zu den
Leuten die nicht damit gerechnet haben
ich habe gesagt doch Quatsch macht er
doch nicht der macht er den dicken Maxe
und droht so ein bisschen und dann ist
einmarschiert
so und jetzt geht es um noch mehr als
die friedliche Existenz der Ukraine
jetzt geht es um die Existenz der Welt
die Politiker
scheinen das nicht begreifen zu wollen
es ist ehrlich gesagt für mich logisch
nicht mehr nachvollziehbar aber die
Menschen wissen es besser das sehen wir
an euch die ihr hier steht
vor allem auch die älteren die noch den
Krieg erlebt haben oder die Erzählung
vom Krieg kennen
laut einer aktuellen vorschau-umfrage
sind 56% aller Deutschen gegen weitere
Waffenlieferungen
[Applaus]
den Ostdeutschland dass er hier
heute gut vertreten ist weil wir
befinden uns ja im östlichen Teil
Deutschlands in Ostdeutschland sind 71
Prozent 71%
gegen weitere Waffenlieferung und für
Verhandlungen
unsere Kritiker spotten wir Pazifisten
hätten ja nur Angst wir werden Feiglinge
in der Tat wir die wir hier heute stehen
wollen keinen Heldentod sterben
und auch nicht den Atomtod
aber diesmal Atom diesen Atom Tod waren
wir nach Hiroshima noch nie so nah wie
heute
das kann man kann man sehr leicht sich
darüber informieren
wer also in der Situation keine Angst
hat der ist entweder ein Dummkopf oder
ein
[Applaus]
wo ist denn eigentlich diese dröter
era also darauf stehen wir heute hier
trotz dieses Zunahme ist an
Beschimpfungen Verdrehungen und
Informationen der über Sarah Wagenknecht
und mich hinweggenommen ist doch wir
lassen uns nicht einschüchtern auch
nicht von diesem
[Applaus]
wir lassen uns auch nicht einschüchtern
von diesem wirklich lächerlichen Gerede
der mangelnden Distanz so extrem Rechten
wie absurd ist das denn
Frauen wie Sarah und mich
aufzufordern wir sollen uns von rechts
distanzieren unser ganzes Leben
unsere ganze Engagement ist wenn Sie
wollen links wir sind für soziale
Gerechtigkeit wir sind gegen Gewalt wir
sind gegen Krieg
das das
[Applaus]
nannte man früher Links
ja
jetzt weiß ich gar nicht mehr viele von
denen die sich heute Links nennen ob da
nicht schon die rechte anfängt
also ich finde es wird sehr schwierig zu
definieren was links und recht ist und
ich schlage vor dass wir uns einfach
gegenseitig an unseren Taten messen und
nicht an längst Lehren ausgehöhlten
ausgehöhlten Etiketten
und wir stehen jetzt hier weil wir nicht
tatenlos aber zu sehen wollen wie jeden
Tag hunderte Menschen geopfert werden
wir stehen hier weil wenn ich tatenlos
zusehen wollen wie die Gefahr eines
Atomkrieges Krieges leichtfertig immer
näher kommt wir stehen hier weil das
Sterben ein Ende nehmen muss
[Applaus]
und wir danken den über 600.000 Menschen
die innerhalb von nur zwei Wochen dass
meine Fest für Frieden unterzeichnet
haben sowas hat dieses Land noch nicht
gesehen
[Applaus]
noch nicht mal das die Politiker
erreicht dann haben wir einfach die
falschen Politiker
[Applaus]
nicht das Volk ist falsch sondern seine
Vertreter wenn sie das nicht einsehen
wollen
[Applaus]
ich hoffe übrigens wir sind bald eine
Million
Unterzeichner und falls jemand immer
noch nicht unterzeichnet hat dann aber
überrascht erklären lassen wie das geht
mit Chance auch
und es ist wunderbar es ist wunderbar
dass ihr alle hier seid und mit uns für
den Frieden aufsteht
das das was wir gerade heute hier
erleben
ist der Beginn einer Bürgerbewegung die
Peter nötig ist danke
[Applaus]
okay ja liebe Freunde und Freunde es war
furchtbar kalt aber ich hoffe wir haben
euch erwärmt und nicht mir zumindest hat
es das Herz gewärmt dass ihr alle hier
war dass ihr so viele war dass er das
Wetter und alles auf euch genommen habt
das ist wirklich toll
und ich möchte auch eine Sache noch
sagen also unsere Helferinnen und Helfer
die bitte ich jetzt auf die Bühne all
diejenigen ohne die diese Kundgebung
nicht hätte organisiert werden können
weil ihr müsst einfach auch sehen Alice
ich auch Erich Fahrt und andere wir
machen ja vieles aber so aus eigener
Kraft eine Kundgebung auf die Beine zu
stellen das haben wir alle noch nicht
gemacht Erich Vater hat mir vorhin
gesagt es ist eine erste Kundgebung für
mich ist es zwar nicht die erste aber
ich habe auch noch nie eine so mit
selbstorganisiert und ohne unsere
Helferinnen und Helfer den ich ja auch
noch mal ganz herzlich danken möchte
wäre das alles so nicht möglich gewesen
deswegen kommt bitte auf die Bühne kommt
bitte alle zu uns hier
und einen Satz
einen Satz möchte ich auch noch sagen
ihr wisst ja es wird immer auch mit
zahlenpolitik gemacht also ich bin auch
nicht jemand der immer gerne sozusagen
sich was vormacht und so tut als sei man
ganz viel wenn man nicht viele ist aber
ehrlich gesagt wenn ihr teilweise
verbreitet wird es seien hier 5000 Leute
gewesen oder 10.000 also sorry ich kenne
Kundgebung mit 5000 Leuten auch mit
10.000 nein wir sind hier viel viel mehr
unsere Ordner sagen wir sind 50.000 und
ich denke so wir sind wir auch und
deswegen das tragen wir von heute
wirklich auch nach draußen das ist eine
riesengroße Friedenskundgebung gewesen
und es wird auch nicht die letzte sein
sondern es ist der Anfang und wir werden
noch mehr werden deswegen vielen Dank
fürs Kommen und beim nächsten Mal sind
wir alle wieder dabei und bringen noch
einen mit herzliches Dankeschön
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja also soweit die Veranstaltung live
aus Berlin mit Sahra Wagenknecht und
Alice schwarze ich würde da gerne mal
zitieren was SARAH Wagen nicht gesagt
hat das ist heute der Startschuss für
eine neue starke Friedensbewegung
gewesen ist das Pfeifen im Wald
Wunschdenken oder könnte sowas ein
Startschuss für eine Friedensbewegung
wirklich sein also mir fällt es schwer
dass mit den 80er Jahren zu vergleichen
wo ich das noch selbst seinerzeit auch
mitbekommen habe ich glaube durchaus
dass es zu einer weiteren Polarisierung
der Debatte in Deutschland führt ich
glaube aber auch dass die Unterstützung
der Ukraine nach wie vor auch stark
bleiben wird
der Unterschied zwischen der
Friedensbewegungen in den 80er Jahren
und das was hier waren echt und schwarze
initiiert haben
das ist eine gute gute Frage ich sehe
ein paar Parallelen ja die Parallelen
haben damit zu tun ähnlich wie früher
bei der Friedensbewegung in den 80er
Jahren kommt da kam damals das Thema
Sowjetunion so werde ich Aufrüstung
Unterdrückung der Alliierten etc so gut
wie überhaupt nicht vor auch damals war
der Adressat alleine die USA die böse
Rüstungsindustrie und sozusagen der
Westen ähm das haben wir jetzt auch ja
ab und zu mal der Name Putin aber man
hat immer den Eindrucks auch in den
Manifest das findet sich in den ersten
beiden Sätzen aber dann der Rest des
Manifestes da wird nicht an Herrn Putin
appelliert der ja der ergressor ist ja
sondern der der Appell richtet sich an
den Westen und richtet sich die an die
Ukraine und ich finde es eine
unglaubliche Arroganz und anders
irgendwie hier für die Menschen in der
Ukraine gesprochen wird von Frau
Schwarzer und Frau Wagenknecht die
sozusagen vereint werden und gar nicht
gefragt werden wir wissen alle Umfragen
die wir haben dass die Menschen gerade
vor dem Hintergrund dieser Gräueltaten
eher weiterkämpfen müssen und das in
Freiheit wichtiger ist sogar als
Ereignis leben ja und das zeigt sich
bereits in den alten Umfragen wenn ich
das noch kurz anführen darf in den
Umfragen in den vier oblasten bereits
vor 2014 vor der Einnahme von der Krim
gab es dort keine Mehrheit die zurück
nach Russland wollte das sind die vier
östlichen genau die Russland sozusagen
für sich ähm auch per Verfassung
sozusagen bereits in das eigene
Staatsterritorium überführt hat ja seit
2014 haben wir gesehen das sind
gesellschaftlichen Wandel der gerade
auch in diesen ostregionen und das die
ursprüngliche Anzahl derjenigen die sich
eine Rückkehr in die Russische
Föderation vorstellen können noch
weitaus abgesunken ist ja ähm also wenn
Frau Schwarzer und Frau Wagenknecht
heute für die Ukrainer sprechen dann
nehmen sie offenbar die Meinung der
Ukrainer absolut nicht zur Kenntnis
sondern sie glauben genau wie Herr Putin
für die Ukraine sprechen zu können und
das ist eine unglaubliche Arroganz und
Anmaßung wir können das gleich weiter
einordnen ich möchte an der Stelle noch
mal kurz zu meinem Kollegen Vase
schalten ein Hinweis an dieser Stelle
wenn ich richtig informiert wird
erwarten wir bei Ihnen demnächst zum
Gespräch alles schwarzer und beginnen
möchte ich mit der Frage ob sie ein
bisschen nähere Informationen dazu haben
wie viel Teilnehmer denn bei dieser
Veranstaltung waren wir haben gerade
Sarah Wagenknecht gehört die hat von bis
zu 50.000 gesprochen hat das irgendwas
mit Realismus zu tun
also in der Tat hat Sahra Wagenknecht am
Ende der Rede sich noch quasi einmal
beschwert und hat gesagt es würde
verbreitet dass nur fünf bis zehntausend
Teilnehmer hier wären in der Tat voll
Beginn der Veranstaltung hat die Polizei
gesagt 5000 Teilnehmer dann jetzt habe
ich gerade eben vor wenigen Sekunden
kann ich quasi sagen noch mal mit der
Polizeipressestelle Rücksprache gehalten
und die Polizei beziffert hier die
Teilnehmer auf 13
zweite wichtige Frage auch noch mal gab
es irgendwelche Vorfälle bezüglich der
Frage sind hier Symbole gezeigt worden
die im Vorab verboten worden sind zum
Beispiel da hatte man ja große Angst das
sogenannte z-symbol was ja die
russische Armee und auch die russischen
Streitkräfte benutzt haben bei ihrem
Angriff auf die Ukraine und da hat mir
die Polizei auch noch mal gesagt nein
Symbole hätte sie nicht gesehen aber man
hat das auch zurückgeführt auf eine sehr
starke
Polizeipräsenz also man sei sehr wachsam
gewesen es hätte das war das einzige was
die Polizei noch gesagt hat das deckt
sich auch mit meinen
mit dem was ich hier beobachten konnte
das beispielsweise wenn der Name
Annalena baerbock gefallen ist der
bundesaußenministerin da gab es dann
sehr viele Berufe und auch abfällige
Bemerkungen also das ist gleich das was
man hier besonders noch mal hervorheben
kann aber ansonsten relativ ruhiger
Verlauf ja wir warten jetzt eigentlich
noch auf eine der Initiatoren nämlich
Alice Schwarzer die hat sich auch noch
mal in ihrer Rede jetzt hier auch noch
mal an die Teilnehmerinnen und
Teilnehmer gewandt hat auch noch mal
gesagt dass sie dann kommt sie auch
gerade in diesen Sekunden sie hat sich
auch noch mal für einen kriegsender
ausgesprochen und ich werde jetzt
ehrlich schwarze eine der
Initiatorin hier direkt begrüßen an der
Veranstaltung Frau Schwarzer danke dass
Sie hier sind
Frau Schwarzer Ausstand für die Frieden
heißt ihre Veranstaltung Aufstand das
klingt so ein bisschen nach
volksausstand aber wir haben doch eine
Demokratie da brauchen wir doch keinen
Volksaufstand
doch es gibt ja eine gewisse Kluft
zurzeit zwischen der politischen Klasse
und dem Volk wir alle Umfragen und diese
wunderbare friedliche Veranstaltung
sagen uns dass die Mehrheit der Menschen
endlich Verhandlungen für den Frieden
will und dass sie gegen immer weitere
Aufrüstung ist und da wir sehen heute
dass wir sehr viele sind die das
wünschen
wir machen eben
schließe ich die Versammlung
ich wollte was ich nicht ganz verstehe
ist der friedensbegriff eigentlich heißt
es auch immer Frieden ist doch also das
ist Frieden jetzt mit einmal das Recht
der stärkeren weil sie fordern ja einen
waffenstopp und das würde ja bedeuten
dass die Ukraine zusammenbrechen würde
schon wieder Gottes Willen wir fordern
das endlich
verhandelt wird und bevor man verhandeln
kann muss man sagen wir wollen
miteinander reden da gibt es dann
erstmal einen
Waffenstillstand und dann gibt es
Gespräche und dann gibt es Kompromisse
und dann hofft man das endlich ein Ende
ist mit dem Sterben und wieder
Zerstörung aber wissen Sie ich finde das
nicht den Moment ich habe in den letzten
Wochen so viel diskutiert und gucken Sie
sich das so einfach mal an klar
das Mikrofon müssen sie mir in der Hand
schon lassen Frau Schwarz Frau Schwarzer
aber wenn man noch mal sie sind ja
Feministin das haben sie auch eben noch
mal in ihrer Rede betont und ist es ja
so wir haben von vielen Gräueltaten in
diesem Krieg gehört die ukrainischen
Frauen sind vergewaltigt worden ob es
systematisch ist das wird sicherlich
noch geklärt werden müssen Sie sich
nicht auch für das ukrainische Volk
einsetzen das ja so schwer von der
russischen Invasion getroffen wurde
wovon reden Sie Herr Kollege wer setzt
sich mehr als wir hier für das
ukrainische Volk ein wissen sie Waffen
töten und wir möchten dass ich länger in
der Ukraine gestorben wird im ersten
Jahr sind schon 250.000 Menschen dort
gestorben reden wir nicht von der
vergewaltigten Frauen reden wir nicht
von den traumatisierten Kindern und
inzwischen nach einem Jahr Krieg wird
uns gesagt dieser Krieg ist militärisch
ist nicht zu gewinnen man muss
verhandeln das Sagen vor allem die die
kenntnisreichen Militärs und nun ist von
einem abnutzungskrieg die Rede man
Stelle manchmal dieses Unwort des Jahres
vor abnutzungskrieg ja also Menschen
werden abgenutzt aber noch mal was ich
was ich ein bisschen heute auch in den
Reden vermisst habe und vielleicht
können sie es aber jetzt hier auch noch
mal ganz klar sagen sie sehen schon den
Aggressor Russland und sie fordern auch
würden sie damit übereinstimmen mit der
UN-Konvention die ja vorgestern
verabschiedet wurde Russland muss sich
komplett zurückziehen aus dem besetzen
gewesen selbstverständlich Russland muss
ich natürlich russland ist der Aggressor
der brutale Aggressor und Russland muss
sich aus den am 24 Februar besetzen
Gebieten zurückziehen das ist doch
selbstverständlich und die Ukraine muss
dafür eine Garantie des Westens bekommen
eine Sicherheitsgarantie das ist klar
das sind die Basics ja äh aber warum
reden wir nicht jetzt darüber und er
sind drei Jahren wenn doch eine
Millionen Menschen gestorben ist einfach
skandalös dieser Krieg sie haben noch
mal gesagt sie müssen nicht beweisen
dass gegen Rechts sind das war noch mal
ich war noch mal eine ja ihrer ganz
klaren Äußerung trotzdem muss man ja
sagen dass Manifest dass sie so
ausgerufen haben man die Aufstand für
den Frieden das ist unterzeichnet worden
von vielen rechten unter anderem Tino
krupala er ist ja der AFD ehrlich drehen
Sie sich doch mal um gucken sich die
Menschen an das Manifest ist von 600.000
Menschen unterzeichnet worden darunter
ist ein Herr krupperland und na und hier
können Sie die mal fragen gucken sich
mal hier die Rechtsradikalen an die hier
stehen ja die angeblich das Manifest
unterzeichnet haben das ist das Volk wir
sind es leid und wir wollen nicht ähm
die vermehrt werden und als rechte
abgestempelt werden wenn wir Frieden
fordern es gibt ja nichts was linker ist
als Frieden sie haben noch mal gesagt
das fand ich auch eine ganz interessante
Bemerkung sie haben gesagt sie sind das
Volk und sie würden mehr sozusagen haben
als sie gewählten Volksvertreter aber
das würde ja die Demokratie ein bisschen
hier bei uns aushebeln
sowas nennt man nennt man die sind
vielleicht jung dafür wenn ich das sagen
darf sowas nennt man außer
parlamentarischen Protest ich war mein
Leben lang in der außer
parlamentarischen Politik also in
Bewegung ich bin in keiner Partei und es
ist ganz gut glaube ich wenn ein in
einer Demokratie das Volk auch eine
Stimme hat und auch sagen kann Moment da
macht ihr vielleicht einiges falsch mal
auf uns
herzlichen Dank für das Interview
das war also wer eine der Initiatoren
eines schwarzer die gerade eben hier
auch geredet hat und ja die
Veranstaltung rückt löst sich jetzt so
langsam auf und
wir werden jetzt gebe ich jetzt jetzt
gebe ich einfach mal zurück ins Studio
nach Bonn ja wir haben hier noch kurz
die Gelegenheit zusammen mit Dr Frank
Umbach diese Veranstaltung einzuordnen
ich greife mal auf was alles schwarzer
gesagt hat abnutzungskrieg bedeutet
jahrelange sterben und am Ende muss man
dann doch verhandeln also warum nicht
gleich jetzt verhandeln
natürlich kann der ab sogenannte
abnutzungskrieg noch drei Jahre
stattfinden er kann dies ja zu Ende
gehen zwei Jahre da und niemand weiß das
im Moment und natürlich wenn die Opfer
über die Zeit natürlich höher aber noch
mal ja sie brauchen dann auf beiden
Seiten jemand der verhandeln will und
das sehe ich äh im Moment eben nicht äh
Putin hat das die letzten Tage noch mal
ganz klar gemacht er hat keine
Kompromissbereitschaft signalisiert und
es geht ihn um nicht weniger als die
Auslöschung der Integrität der
Souveränität und auch der Kultur einer
unabhängigen Ukraine es geht nicht nur
um diese vier Oblaste es geht nicht nur
um die Krim das sind die Kriegsziele die
ja im Sommer
2021 in den Brief formuliert hat und die
er jetzt wiederholt hat ich darf auch
daran erinnern dass vor wenigen Tagen in
einem Artikel in der Financial Times
interessanterweise lavrov noch mal
interviewt worden ist bzw er hat dort
offensichtlich zugegeben
dass er selbst nicht informiert war über
den Einmarsch und der hat dann zitiert
dass ich Putin gegenwärtig eigentlich
nur von drei Menschen wirklich beraten
lässt und das ist Peter der Große Ivan
der schreckliche und Katharina die Große
und alle drei seinen Tod
und das spricht eine ganze Menge weil
die innenpolitische Konstellation über
die all diese sozusagen
friedensabhologieten sprechen die
innenpolitische Situation in Russland
muss ja so sein dass überhaupt
Friedensverhandlungen auf Seiten Putin
stattfinden können und da sehen wir dass
die innenpolitischen machtgewicht ist
sich verlagert haben wo Putin noch mehr
als am Anfang des Krieges von ultra
Nationalisten von der wagnertruppe
sowohl politisch wie militärisch
abhängig geworden ist das heißt die
Voraussetzung für Friedensverhandlungen
leider sind stand heute deutlich
schlechter als zu Beginn des Krieges und
diese innenpolitischen Konstellation
sind wie gesagt die Voraussetzungen das
tut den überhaupt Kompromisse macht ja
und diese innenpolitischen
Konstellationen werden in keinster Weise
von Frau Schwarzer Frau Wagenknecht und
vielen anderen sozusagen adressiert
greife jetzt mal auf was Wagenknecht und
gesagt habe es kann ja sein dass über
viele Jahre sich da gar nichts ändert an
dieser Situation das Putin in Russland
an der Macht bleibt und dass er seine
Vorstellungen im Wesentlichen gar nicht
ändert dann bliebe ja nur die Frage kann
man Putin besiegen und da zitiere ich
jetzt mal in dem Fall Sarah Wagenknecht
man kann die Atom macht Russland nicht
besiegen also es ist historisch
eindeutig falsch die USA haben als
atomacht im Vietnamkrieg verloren sie
haben als atomacht in Afghanistan
verloren genauso wie die so wird Union
als Atom macht in ihrem eigenen
Afghanistan Krieg verloren haben die
Atommächte haben konventionelle Kriege
verloren und Sie sind auf beiden Seiten
am Ende nicht haben nicht zu den
Nuklearwaffen gegriffen weil sie beide
wussten und das gilt auch für Putin dass
das auch für ihn und für Russland dann
die völlige Vernichtung bedeuten würde
und Putin ist alles aber er ist nicht
irrational er hat eine andere
Rationalität er denkt in anderen
Kategorien als wir das ist etwas was wir
lernen müssen das solche autoritäre
führe außerhalb von Demokratien und dem
europäischen
transatlantischen Kulturkreisen anderen
Kategorien denken das heißt aber nicht
irrational das ist alles nachvollziehbar
ja aber sie sind keine solchen Volks-
oder Selbstmörder wie wir sozusagen da
hinein interpretieren wollen jetzt haben
sie ja im Laufe unseres Gesprächs sehr
deutlich klar gemacht dass sie die
Argumente von alles schwarzer und Sarah
Wagen nicht nicht teilen können ich
frage sie aber trotzdem war diese
Veranstaltung heute vielleicht für die
Debatte in Deutschland trotzdem etwas
Gutes weil es eben uns dazu bringt die
Argumente auszutauschen und aufgrund
dieser Debatte eben dann die richtige
Entscheidung also jeder für jede
Demokratie ist eine Debatte hilfreich
und es hilft uns auch sozusagen die
Argumente zu schärfen und zu
hinterfragen auch russische operative
die häufig völlig unkritisch übernommen
werden wenn Herr Putin von sozusagen dem
Schutz der Russen im Ausland spricht
dann wird zum Beispiel kaum
unterschieden spricht der von den
ethnischen Russen oder spricht der auch
von denen die Russisch sprechen ja diese
Dinge müssen sozusagen immer hinterfragt
werden und da hilft diese Debatte weil
sie schafft die Argumentation und dann
muss auch auf der anderen Seite auf der
Regierung Seite auf meiner Seite
sozusagen immer seine eigenen
Argumentation überprüfen und sie so an
den Gegenargumenten sozusagen messen und
das hilft auf jeden Fall der Demokratie
dann darf ich mich bedanken dass sie uns
durch diesen Nachmittag begleitet haben
das liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer
war unsere Live Übertragung der
Veranstaltung Aufstand für Frieden in
Berlin mit Sarah Wagenknecht und Alice
Schwarzer vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse